piste de motocross de châteaurenard
terrain d'entraînement favori darnal de
frustration alors il participe au début
janvier à son troisième dakar
eichhoffen alors non l'existence chez
nous depuis
trois ans à son premier dakar il a
souhaité venir dans notre
dans notre dans notre club alors j'ai
dit oui avec grand plaisir on est on est
pas une grosse structure une
cinquantaine de licenciés et quand on a
un pilote qui participe au dakar bon il
ya quand même une certaine fierté on est
on est on est on est content pour lui
mais ça reste vrai l'image est là le
pilotage il ya le cardio le mental donc
bon tout ce qu'il faut pour refaire une
belle performance première moto à trois
ans découverte du pilotage à 5 mais ça
ne l'intéresse pas ce n'est que vers ces
ans qu'arnold se lance vraiment dans le
motocross et commence à penser au dakar
tradition familiale
je suis rentré dans grâce à mon père qui
a lui fait 25 ricard au début c'était
quelque chose qui me paraissent un peu
inaccessible au niveau
financier budget sont assez conséquents
et en 2013 il m'a payé mon premier
rallye est en fait tout de suite
vraiment adoré et puis bah après on
s'est bougé pour trouver les moyens de
partir et est depuis 2010 est j'ai fait
mon premier dakar et maintenant j'ai
l'impression que je peux pas trop
m'arrêter quoi pour le repérer sur sa
ktm 450 modèle 2019
rien de plus simple le numéro 45 tout un
symbole
ces numéros que mon père avait à ses
débuts qu'il ait eue pendant plusieurs
années
donc c'était un peu une fierté pour moi
de pouvoir continuer en ayant son numéro
et puis bah vu qu'on est dans le loiret
on est du 45 donc c'est un petit c'est
un petit plus arnold russie sera
supporté par tous les membres de moto
verte châteaurenard son président à
rêver en voyant les motos du père dans
son magasin montargis aujourd'hui il
soutient le fils pour la petite histoire
papa est encore de la partie mais comme
copilote aux voitures jean et arnold sur
le dakar une histoire de famille en
quelque sorte